week we've got news about games we got
debates about games and we've got two
guys on couch then I'm gonna introduce
right now Andy Baumann game Decker
what's up guys hey are you doing I'm
doing well we're here to talk about
mafia three because mafia three was
announced this morning even though like
it's kind of been rumored for like years
now yeah we know we're on what do you
wanna know about mafia I want to know
what you want in mafia Andy I want to
know next week we're gonna be getting
more information about it but until then
like you guys have played some mafia
significant amounts what do you want
from this it's coming back after five
years I kind of left mafia to feeling
like all right that's enough cool when I
did the mob we did the mafia thing
nailed it we nailed it we got it mafia
one came out of nowhere it was amazing
it was absolutely brilliant the city was
alive like in a way that even now games
have a struggle like getting at cuz it
that you like cops pull you over for
speeding like you had to live in that
world you had to inhale you a traffic
laws or suffer the consequences and you
could like ride on the L train and like
goat it's like you're going to work or
whatever and then it's like oh now you
gotta like cap subdued Duke run and do
crimes and that's because you fell into
wrong crowd or whatever like it so it
felt it had this cool feeling of it and
also maybe I was younger and more
susceptible to it well that was 2002
yeah I was a while ago so we're seeing
greg saavn in the video review with the
baseball and then 2010 eight years later
mafia two came out and it was alright
it's very highly reviewed by kevin van
orden really point five Wow okay it was
more of like a shooter than the first
game as far as like you had cover
mechanics and you could you know blast
dudes with an array of guns and you know
if it was alright so I had the drive in
the city but it just didn't feel quite
as our revolutionary as the first one
did yeah like the city in mafia two it
was it was cool it looked cool but there
wasn't much in there it almost felt like
a linear game even though it was in a
big city and I think like why is this an
open-world exactly that was kind of my
question even carried over to the end
like once you finish the game I believe
that was it right like you couldn't go
back in the world in free roam unless
you wanted to start a new game so do you
think like so there
a question of open world versus linear
right i mean you know if you're going to
have an open world you got to kind of do
something with it otherwise it's just so
much space for you to traverse on your
way and possibly get busted by cops with
like really terribly handling cars from
yeah yeah you like try to drift there
and get points for drifting i guess like
whatever get points for drifting in a
car from the 50s there's a whole bunch
of weird details necking like everybody
could like go home and like drink beer
from the fridge oh yeah like that it was
like and there's playboys yeah just like
scattered around there's a collectible
right you'd like go around the city and
try to pick up the I have to admit I
would like try and find out like I'm
gonna like there's a grown-ass man who
can just go into a store or and buy some
you have a choice find it in a garbage
can not to dwell too much but these were
like from the era well that was another
thing cool so that's another thing the
period sort of accuracy about mafia has
always been like a real strong suit yeah
and you know in terms of the cars the
outfits the sort of the music the way
that the world is constructed these
little details so if we're looking at
mafia now what kind of time period would
you want to see it in so yeah but they
should tear it all down and start over
right uh-huh because we've done this mob
thing italian-made men yeah I don't to
be like in new york city again yeah it's
like I want something more on something
different so we were joking early like
what if they made it like it's still
called mafia but what if it's just like
the modern drug game yeah and it's like
cartel body more cig Maryland or
whatever oh the wire yeah murder Lynn
it's the wired whatever no that'd be
cool like if it's but it's probably not
gonna be that but sure maybe they just
take the setting somewhere else where
there is no there's never been a mob
movie in I don't know Louisiana
Louisiana yeah that's one of the rumors
that's been going around and they teased
an image sort of released today that had
you do see some Spanish moss on the
trees there on the sides and you see
some cars that look like uh I'm no I'm
no car ologist but that's like 70 esque
right i mean we're past the 50s maybe
60s 70s it's sort you see for people
they're lined up a thing
one of them is a woman and the others
appear to be dudes so character has been
another like real strong suit in mafia
historically that writing and the way
they sort of you know it's it's an
interesting story and so you know don't
yeah it gets real elaborate into there's
like different mobs on mobs killing
people that you want to save and then
you got to like help them and then
everybody dies and someone's an FBI
informant and then you're maybe gonna
die and fade to black what at what point
do you become a schoolteacher and or a
dock worker and just lament the failing
infrastructure of the city that you live
it yeah hopefully from soon hopefully
this is gonna happen again no a
two-story I mean it almost kind of felt
like a Scorsese video game sort of just
the way it was set up I mean it wasn't
was on the same level mm-hm but I mean
I'd like to see something again like
that like focus more on storytelling
once again if it is in the what's it
called the Louisiana area if it's in the
bayou that does seem to be pulling from
like the first season of True detective
like that just feeling and that
storytelling and I think games these
kind of games have always liked pulled
from movies late Scorsese you know that
so it's like yeah they want to keep
going with those threads and like yeah
so because there's definitely a
different flavor to like that kind of
fast pace New York like a very Italian
influence sort of new gangster ethos and
then like the sort of may be slower
southern pace of just like you know like
the days are drawn out in this
suffocating heat and like there's a lot
more sort of rural spaces involved black
magic yeah there's like this Caribbean
influence in there too so it is you know
they're definitely cinematic tradition
and of course like with TV with true
detective something for them to draw on
and I think that's been a strength of
mafia in the past and i think the cool
thing about the louisiana setting if
that is the case it's not something you
typically see in games the last time i
think i was in louisiana and game in a
game was like tony hawk's underground or
something like that like yeah his left 4
dead 2 somewhere oh you were celebrity
runs well and also in battlefield
hardline there's a swamp scene but
that's like my aunt that's Florida
somewhere but I was like a fan bow
you know going through the swamp but
having a live open world that I think I
think could be a really really strong
feature for the game hopefully set it
apart from you know like Grand Theft
Auto and these other sort of free
bringing to life a different kind of
city a different feel and yeah mafia 3
announced today gonna be learning more
about mafia 3 at Gamescom next week on
wednesday i believe the fifth their
trailer dropping oh yeah there's like
the whole like thing is gonna setting
probably trailer big thing coming out of
gamescom next week let us know what you
think about mafia 3 in the comments
below what you want to see Andy jig
thank you guys so much dude thanks for
having yeah good stuff